so we have to talk a little more about  deadpool  tell me everything about your appearance  in the doctor strange movie oh wow mark  fun  it's like the least uh uh least covert  trap i've ever seen in my life you know  what is it is there a point of me saying  to are you in the doctor strange i don't  know that was that was a 1978 leg hold  trap from russia like i saw that from a  hundred miles away um yeah i don't i'm  not really supposed to i guess i'm  really not supposed to say anything  about that but i'm really not in the  movie  i'm not supposed to say anything but i'm  really not in the movie you just said  something and you could be lying and you  could be lying i could be an unreliable  narrator but i promise you i'm  [Music]  we're good there's a team of people that  will neutralize you as soon as you leave  leave here